we could okay so so now we have the
final talk on this three talk series on
MIP star equals re and our next speaker
is a professor's John frangie from
University of Technology Sydney with
another quarter on this paper and we'll
wrap up this series
okay thanks Anders second case an echo
[Music]
so this is Jen fangy totaling from
Sydney Australia and I should thank the
organizers for making this happening I'm
given the time of crisis and also I
noticed that the shift of the schedule
so that leaks easier for me my time zone
so I will talk about a lucky star in
Kasauli part of this series of talks and
that is I want to get up on techniques
that you've seen so far in the workshop
and to give the proof of an abstruse ye
I'm ticularly and John's talk so this is
John work with and tomorrow on and Harry
and first I'd like to give you some back
wanted to be sure that we're on the same
page which table is MIT you have seen
this many times I won't go into details
and you have also seen Magic Square
claims on you can think of the game as
eternity need to like to prefer claim
and and the cinder won't emphasize that
if we look at this games the power of
the actual prover where the power come
from is set free because like we can
interpret this propose to cross checks
and and what means that we we have a
very interesting question distribution
and you look from a list view and bobs
field the the new partial information of
other players information but not
complete information the questions are
correlated in some way but it's it's
some interesting structures in the Eifel
look at okay interesting
so adding entanglement which in the the
players you have class on my P star and
and pioneered in the work of cleave at
all and I think like it it's beautiful
because connects our multi proven to
have proofs to play our inequalities and
also notice the Sun is problem caused by
entanglement because like in tango
strategies we have higher values so
previously classically song what course
will not be sound and it also opens the
door to developments and applications of
unlocks of many powerful ideas in inter
to proves like because parallel
petitions and PCPs
most of these are the techniques that we
use in our work um so we give some
definitions of the model that we study
uconn local claims and it's a very
simple object we have fun excel question
sets X&Y and finite answer sets a and B
and the question fusion new are X Y and
also I decided given the tuple of
question and answers we want to make
sure accept or not and assume has been
telling you we would also consider
family of games defined by therefore
which is a pair of torn machines one is
called as simpler and the other is the
decider and so easy to understand the
role of DS have index and and
the question also to pool and the
machine assembler s basically it's
implementing the sampling procedure and
can sync over something to secure as
from this random cz apply some function
LA and LB to get the questions for Bob
so the machine is actually specifying
the computation of an LP in some sense
and then when we hardwired the index
then you would get n zkn defined by the
the Turing machine called VN that's the
station that we were used in the talk so
once we have the game or we can consider
to whether this one is quite entangle
value and and basically a strategy
integrity is a state and a measurement
on the scale is in the tensor calm space
and and then the integral value is you
maximizing over all possibilities of the
winning property and that's expression
for the winning property and what's
magic 4matic square is that value is
integral is one even though that
consistent has no classical consignment
satisfying assignment and basically this
class of a map estimate is about the
problem of approximating the value to
some precision given certain size and
very similarly to this definition we
also consider committing operators
affinities differences now we have a
single given space and there's no tensor
structure and we require that a list of
operators and Bob's operators are
commuting and this gives you a
definition of commuting value by
optimizing overall strategies and the
case you have seen on this problem in
talk citizens open ask whether these two
values are the same for all kids and if
you mention that for finite dimensional
purpose these two values to coincide and
so it's really a problem
but what happens when space H is there
are two algorithms that we know for this
two values the first is that Jeff is
only just do not have search for better
ten subtract securities of increasing
dimensions and increasing Precision's
and just gives you sequence of various
approaches at the intent of value of our
stock the other hydrogen is is
non-trivial and basically it's non
commutative version of sum of squares
rocky also known in the community as in
play hockey for in this reference they
will give you as a sequence of recipes
whose value converges to value the
commuting of the value for above so the
first terrorism implies that the
classroom at least or is in our e and a
more interesting consequence is that if
citizen problem has positive answer
meaning that these two values are the
same then you have an algorithm for
approximately this value because you can
all trade in between than one and so
that's a complexity theory consequence
of thousands column having positive
answer but what we found out is that
actually an app store equals re so
there's no algorithm that we can
approximate the connect value because it
is as hard as hot a problem in some
sense gives like a complete
characterization of the class and AP
store and I guess in like following the
same of Irvine strengths cop
entanglement spooky action at a distance
we like to call that our result is a
spooky compress the other distance it is
also interesting to to seeker and the
results from the barony quality
perspective we see that it's a
computability surrett repair a new
quality because like john bell tell us
that for certain games value is
different shank Frank I there's a bit of
echo when you speak so
could you maybe like turn your volume a
bit lower or move closer to the mic or I
don't know I don't know why it happens
yeah okay
this is I would recommend that maybe you
just hold your microphone closer to your
mouth
[Music]
because like if you think about what
jumper is telling us is you have certain
games where the values are different but
our results isn't if you look at the
compatibility of this values they're
different
there's always have consequences in
physics and mathematics
it gives necromancerr to citizens
problem and and gives a reputation of
Thomson burning conjecture which is a
major problem in the Opera direct
[Music]
discussions in wooden stock so this is a
very quick introduction and next I would
reveal the key ideas and techniques that
we rely on basically you have seen most
of them maybe it's a good point if you
have questions so let me start I see it
the first thing that a very technical
singer we rely on is the distance
measures if you look at the papers like
maybe 70 80 % of the proofs are using
this language it has been wrong for a
while maybe 10 years now
and it evolved from paper to paper and
recommend that you meet in John's paper
because it's a really nice way to
present what we need and there are two
different measures that are important
one is called state dependent distance
it's a measure between two set of
measurements acting on the same space
like you also need a consistency imagine
measures the distance between two set of
measurements that acting on different
spaces Alice and Bob space
and using cautious words that have
interesting properties have been shown
and basically that's the main tour that
we reason about when we massage the
asparagus to argue about properties
that's I mean in technique that use and
then another early technique that we
rely on is trying to solving the Asami's
problem of entanglement and they said
because this entitlement resistant
techniques so for example you can you
can do a check for computing track and
and suppose that verifies interest in
the value assignment to variable X but
the verifier would simple another
variable Y and asked Alice to give
assignment to those x and y by putting
the order of x and y the hiding which
we're very good at verify is actually
interested in and I'm doing subjects you
would be able to derive that the the
measurement corresponding to x and y are
approximately commuting the state then
it is like some classical condition that
you can like a situation that is similar
to the classical condition and like you
can also use monopoly of entanglement
and such simple techniques would enable
you to protect entangle games or the
np-hard these are very early
investigations and I guess in that set
of techniques what is surprising and
most important to us is that the low
degree tests and material test and the
test are found to be concerned so these
are are tested that what we used in
class code in Chapter proof systems and
you don't need to like do much of a
modification and and you can you can
have the concern is meaning that having
entanglements between the players the
prefers don't help them to cheat so the
guarantees of these tests are the
structural results of this test meaning
you have a linear function motolinia
function behind us to is it's been
preserved even having dinner and and and
I think that the the first freak suit in
this area and and the results also
allowed so easy to end to mobility prove
that an accident Comedy Store and that's
telling us that at least the column
classes as powerful as a classical cross
so next piece of tour that we need is
ready you have seen in-depth discussion
in undress talk and so I won't repeat
what I mean is basically we would have a
way to enforce the previous two metric
honest measurement X and Z's if you look
at the Magic Square game is all about
community and and community so the
variables that are on the same line or
column are commuting and the variables
like X 1 X 5 would on the same line are
engineering and and community is really
important for us because by this simple
Emily felt like two reflections that
aren't converting approximately then
there will be a new class of muslin so
that these operators are essentially X
and Z and once you have X and Z have
like two dimensional space and you have
fun R cubed this is important because
from the perspective the verifier you
see you send out and receive classical
informations and only by rigidity you
can argue that or there's quantum system
so building the upon the idea of
rigidity we can go beyond country
harness it's not an easy thing to do
like it took us many years to figure it
out and I guess the interesting that
this idea came out that if discussion
Simon since you workshop in 2014 so
thanks Simon's did it for our squad in
the research and the idea is that you
can use on aircraft and code and code
put information for example you have
like a witness state you want to design
know who came from that
but you can do you is you can include
each trivet into using this corner
crafting colic and it's for code and and
each like you you have for prove us and
each poker would hold one cubit of the
included could be for Cubans and use
rigidity we can ensure that prefers
measure honest X and Z measurements on
this included state and then we can do
logical measurement because what
Commandments are can take Callie to to
measure the logical operators and then
we can check energy of the included
state so this is how how we design
protocols for verifying crampy and
another like consequence or rigidity I
think it's important for us because like
it joins the forces of low degree tests
konasana class going to be tests and
rigidity basically it's using order of
magic squares and then stock and you
have powerful game that we call party
basis game basically what gives you is
if you send the question party W what
that is is x and y to the players then
they have to measure the basis in
extends a and report measurement article
so as you can see that in the rigidity
theorem the the measurement that
correspond to this command is
essentially the honest party
measurements and and it's also very
efficient meaning that the messages are
much smaller than the number of qubits
you're testing so this gives you ability
to to self-test and pure sand and you
can
to remember that we have now a primitive
court party W where you can command the
players to do body measurement and
respond with it is important to first to
understand the question tribution like
I've been saying that it's important
that the question traditions of
different games are interesting and for
us the the understanding the question
tradition of the body basis game will
help us to understand how the proof
works so remember that the question
Tavitian are being sampled by first
something a CV and then find some
functions to apply down Xion and send it
to Jason Bob there will be different
types of questions that consider the
points questions and frame questions are
for the logical tests so we need one for
X basis and one for Z basis the pair
types questions are for testing
community of operators that are
commuting and the constraint variable
types are are for the Magic Square game
testing the entity so for example in the
point type so basically all the we'll
have a very uniform format for the
questions they will have like this type
and content formats what type is some
complete set of labels and content is a
vector in finite field f to the 4n plus
2 for example the UX is the the point
for the X measurements and uz is a 24
for Z and we want me to add a
directional vector defining things in
this space after the
and our xrz are for this try to convert
in this high dimensional as it's over f2
to two bits so these are the the what
type of questions that we need in in the
points type of questions we want
revealed at the point of x ux is
revealed or other coordinates are 0 out
you don't let the players to know where
what what the state has in these
registers so just place them by 0 and
you can do this by the reviewing and
hiding technique that John has been
telling you in danger
introspection technique and similarly
for the planes you would first review
the directions and then depending on the
direction you culturally reveal the
point information you don't want to give
the the point where a plea to the player
because that would violate your common
that we want to build interesting
distribution that is no box question so
that's essentially what we gonna need
food for this party business game and
here this the quaff it's like type quaff
like we would what we would do we were
simple an edge and then send the type
one vertex type to to medicine the other
would expected to Bob and also apply
this procedure to to review any hard
information so that's that's how we like
we to find the description and you can
see that is essentially the same as the
party basis in game distribution in
presentations the next idea that we need
is about compression it it is a very
natural thing to consider
once you have I want to prove something
like I'm at least one goes to our Yi but
the idea actually appeared
when we want to try to improve the lure
bounce remember that I was giving a talk
talk and about classical application of
creamy and and at the end of talk and
Harrow asked the question where they can
go beyond of Crimea and prove maybe like
an ogre games are creepy hard and and I
said at a time that maybe you can build
like more relation sort of the rigidity
conditions right at that time we have
like connectivity and the connectivity
but you can you can give more
sophisticated relations than you able to
prove more I guess I wasn't too far off
the points because later on
Willian find out that you can actually
enforce this kind of conduct simulations
and uses to prove that the set of Conan
correlations no close and simplified his
breakthrough proof of non stability of
linear consistent games but later on
very simple idea came to me and
motivated by the this classical result
of merit and watches basically crappy is
is QM it's not that far from chromate
because it's a single actual matter
right and if you look at the the
structure of this thing it it's almost
like creamy but at some student step you
would like to prove it to pick unitary
but they think body you can do
propagation tracking for this kind of
protocols and what this will give you is
a compression for an IP star so that's
how came up so the compression would
give you now a stories a big game paper
tears players to but you end up with
game where the
sizes and running times of airfryer is
much smaller the problem though is that
we have a problem with a gap and I guess
this table summarizes the situation and
it's even though they lose a gap is also
interesting because if you write down
what we have for the classical case like
an IP and skill down version we have
like a cane for a CSP problem for
example then the message size is
especially small and the complexity goes
down from an actor to MP and the gap for
the mi piel focus constant the gap for
the games triple Eight's
inverse polynomial but by the pitch PC I
mean it can also be a constant now in
the case of quantum that you have a star
when you reduce the size of messages
what this compression theorem give us it
doesn't go down from the I'm a P star
tune to maybe screw down version many
studies it still stays at a medi star
and and that's interesting because we
have seen some differences in these two
setups and ideas and is that we can
amplify the cap from this inverse
polymer to constant then you would have
something like like I'm disability of
the unhappy star so what we want is to
try to amplify the gap and maybe in
today's language is like social
distancing for the completeness and
soreness and and also we like we know
how to do gap and petition in your
classical literature you just use PCP
and and the basic idea is whether it's
easy to screw in some key cities and and
get better results
but that's not that easy because if you
think about all these early results they
are using this including using a
recruiting codes and the property of
error correcting code is that locally
there's no information so the proof was
have like one bit of
and test images I don't like math from
the mixed and there's new information
locally so and all the information is
actually in the parody all of this
player is conscious and this is not a
setting that you can easily work like
using PC piece so then and you already
have seen this the next idea to solve
this problem is the recover idea and
also gives you a different way to prove
compression serum is you let the
previous to sample the questions
themselves and that's introspection and
like to summarize but what is happening
in introspection is actually utilized
recent programs in principle to design
what you want to reveal and what you
want to hide from the measurements of
the EP objects so for that we want to
implement our in an LP and use that to
as the question distribution but you
want the intro expansion to work if you
want so good inch oval primitive and
once the player received this command of
intro they have to measure the EP RS to
get the question why and it's supposedly
this lvl the of Z where Z is Z
measurement calm of the peons and then
once you get the big question you can
measure that in as in original strategy
for the wafer full clear V together
answer a so this is what we want to
achieve and and we have seen examples
that this is possible for distributions
like the low degree tasks the line point
dispersion are used in
okay so that's a very quick discussion
of the techniques that we rely on and
and so the rest of talk I would try to
put everything together and give you a
proof result so in the end we will have
several different steps to do the
compression I guess from John's talk
very nature to to have some
introspection step we want to use this
idea to reduce the size of questions and
also a PCP to reduce the size of answers
and a realization is a pre-processing
step for using PCP and you also need a
parallel petition to recover the cap
because along the way the cap rise is
getting worse and and that's what we
found to be useful in in in the
compression and oh it's not maybe it's
not clear that you have to go from from
one to four it's just some combination
of these steps but we found that this
this sequence would just work and and a
focus would be how to use the
introspection idea that introduced in
John's talk to to do question abduction
and um the question that we need to ask
is what is missing from the protocol
that given by NN and John
so basically the stop is a map is star
vodka and up with a smaller particle but
this talking points has very special
structures basically it's it's the
variant of index because to an IP
protocol of BF but after that it will be
much more complicated game and you
cannot like ticking in and output as an
input
to the procedure and get smaller and
smaller compressed case so the idea then
is very net you want to find some
so-called normal form where you start in
a game of this normal form after the
compression it is a smaller game and is
still in this in this form then we can
apply this arguments recursive so there
are two problems that are that are
important the first is that we want to
understand what kind of distributions
basically it's the answers and this a
decision procedure uneasy we want to
understand this kind of distribution
that we can apply this introspection
technique to it is not that old equation
that we can you can apply to on there's
some very special family of diffusion
that we can apply the introspection
technique and also another question is
what the of contribution with the game
of the compressions and want to make
sure that these two matches and that's
that that will be our number four so
I'll just give you the solution that we
found and and and this is called
condition a linear functions so
basically these are functions if you
remember that from the Z we want to
compute our a of Z and LP of Z and these
are described in the functional value
and LP how you compute the question from
the 1mc collisional inner functions are
very simple it's a generalization of
linear functions so basically you would
choose registers subspace of F to the
end so think of this alarm screen here
as a vector of an entries of elements in
few depth and maybe v1 is just the first
ten elements and if you apply a linear
function to this first ten elements and
then we have some output y1 so y1 is
some linear combination of this entries
may not be one-to-one so we made with
some linear information out of z1 and
that's hiding part and once you have
seen and I learned one by one you can
condition on Y one and and do something
similar to the rest of the bits and you
will choose a space RB 2 and then apply
a function which both like where both
the subspace the word cupids are and and
what function you use are depending on
the the first information by wagon see
and you will plead this our times and we
call out the number of levels of the CR
function you can get y1 + 2 - 4 y el and
then output of the function is a
collection of all the Y's to sum over
all this wise you get Y and then the
linear function as condition when a
function is just from Z - this wine so
it's extension of linear functions with
sequence of conditioning of intermediate
output so why we consider such functions
well first of all it's very natural to
consider linear functions because it
works so well with the technique of
introspection basically it's rebuilding
and hiding bringing information and
works we're always XV measurements and
as you can imagine but linear functions
are not enough for us even like in the
classical or did we test you want to
have this player in one discussion
especially in plain dispersion you you
want to review the directions and then
you need to apply some functions at it
dependent depending on this V 1 and V 2
and and after that it's really funny but
if conclude this computation from the
seed to the output a plane is not a
linear function but as no other fish in
the world P 2 level see our function
because the first thing if you're in
your information
register and then you condition on this
directions you reveal the information
about the point where you want point
information partial information one
point you want to build to the plane
player so and and basically you can
verify that see our functions works and
they can model all the question
tribution that we want and they have
very nice closure profits for that point
if we do cover a petition you means on
sale and but for us it's the only
technical part we want to verify that
poly basis game uses sale distribution
and that's easy to do the most natural
part is actually this thing and this is
already been solved in NN and John's
paper so the next thing we want to so we
have a definition of sale functions and
we will see that that you can actually
design an introspection game for this
for sampling distributions so to to make
things simple we consider two levels
sale functions so they all be are one to
two at to your first review information
in our and height information attached
to and then condition on what you've
seen our you said where this are two
years and you read the information and
the highly information in HJ what we
want is in the the primitive of intro
for example and we want the player to
behave in the women where they only
measure this are registers were long to
the beautiful machine but imagine a
thing which is identity on this hiding
registers and also once we have this r1
and r2 z measurements you get the
information Y which is the quest
and then you should also be able to
measure the answer of the input gain
uses this distribution Co diffusion has
questions but how do you set behavior
that's another use of diarrhea of the
data hiding technique the introspection
technique an engine basically what you
can do is the way you ensure that the
interval won't measure h1 and h2 is that
we introduce the measurement and X
measurement and you check that no matter
whether you measure Z or X there will be
all consistent with this intro type of
question and that's that technique
because like the independence of this
intro type on this information in h1 h2
is important we want to make sure that
the unsub a is only depending on why but
not ordered the information that's
important for preserving the information
perspective of the players so the rest
of the construction is easy you want to
make sure that all this the measurements
are honest and this is simple going to
cross-check this sample by the poly V
primitive that we have from the poly
basis management and and similarly for
ensuring this X measurements for some
technical reasons we've introduced
multiple height types where the number
of high type is number of levels so
let's see what we need to check so the
first concept between intro and simple
we would sell like said may be sent into
a to Alice and
into a sample a - to Bob and these
colors are where we check through the
the measurements on this register should
agree and answer they have also should
be the same so that's from from this
information G you can compute by the
linear function a to get Y and also the
answers are the same and then you check
that this Z measurement in sample are
honest by cross-check this with the
pollen type of question
similarly you cross check read and an
intro where really is like you would
only measure the information that you
you need but you would purposely erase
all the information using X measurements
the trick that John has been telling you
and then you want to make sure that this
XS are honest and and we do this by
moving this Z to identity and check that
or thus remaining scenes are consistent
and gradually we check and this axis are
consistent and all this axis are
consistent so it's a chain of checks
leading to this poly X to make sure that
this X measurement are honest
so that gives you the structure the
order the the definition design of the
intro game that we have for a general
condition of linear functions when when
there are two levels and you can easily
extend it to two levels for any constant
now and to summarize what this intro
game is doing you can think of two ways
of playing normal form game so I became
VN which is specified by SN and DN in a
standard way
the very forward sample the random seat
and cause ascend to compute questions
using these functions to get x and y and
then you receive answers for Harrison
Bob and you can use decider to thank you
tell me whether I'll accept or reject
the other way is the introspective way
is you you do this introspection game so
what you develop ever do is first to
play the polly basis game over if you
are of this dimension so the measurement
of the CP ons would give you a Z in this
space I have to do today and and then we
run many parts of the intro game so into
canvas is using the poly basis game as a
sub game so the remaining part of the
game and and that part is what we
introduced in tables and ensures that
players to respect the intro primitive
and lastly you you just send into to
palace and enjoy be to Bob and then
receive X and pay in Y and B because if
you trust that this works the players
has to sample the large question and and
get like do this measurement to get a
large answer and we'll put back then you
can use the decider D to
to test whether accept or reject and so
that's look at if you look at the the
question size of the Polly business game
and the introspection game it is much
smaller than the standard way of playing
games where you need to send all this
after the end of information
how we how we reduce the question using
introspection so I look at as just an
attribution Renault that can I went in
the spirit of our Christian tradition is
important because we want to make sure
that in the end is still good
many pollution and look at the or this
new type of like we have this body basis
types from the poly basis game but which
is complicated but for this new types
they would only consist of the type and
there will be no information needed from
the from the vectors will all be zero
that's because the way the game is
designed and and then you can see that
for each type added for each given type
the information you have can be
completed by from the seat using a serie
function and then the next scene is that
you want to get rid of these types and
those types are forming up three
cognitive graph you want to simulate
this distribution defined by the quad
using commissioners and extrusions and
and that's possible with especially
going like overhead but that's okay
because we only consider finite size
type graphs and another thing that that
was mentioning if you only need constant
levels of conditioning so we'll consider
eight level co-functions we start with
eight level cell functions to this
compression procedure and and we get
eight level sale distribution as the
outcome so that's how the instruction
introspection books then in the next
several steps quickly remind you what
they are
organization and this is because we want
to apply the PSP technique technique and
basically we want one prover to have
every onion for the information so all
the questions X&Y and BMP and B are at
one prover side so and for this to work
we want to require that for the perfect
strategy that we consider the complete a
completeness condition all the
measurements that person Bob uses are
always commuting well they are chameleon
because they are actually on different
hilbert spaces but one day out they need
to be commuting even like removed box
operator to to Alice so when they when
they are operating on the same space and
that's the reason that we actually
required multiple high types in the
intro game remember this table here like
we want to ensure that XS are honest why
don't we just cross-check wheat and
party X well that will introduce the
measurement where the measurement others
decide measure Z and Bob site mayor's X
and that's not commuting but like
introducing mod Ojai types you can you
can avoid this problem everywhere every
time you measures any measurements
Anderson website they are always
clearing in a sense and on the same
space okay so the next step we want to
use pcps and parallel petitions and we
won't spend much time talking about it
because basically it's very similar to
what Adam John was to in their paper
what we want to make sure is that this
transformation won't create the
condition that diffusion is here and
there's some
operations that we did to make this easy
to prove and and then after that you
have like Cain where both the questions
and answers are small now but the the
gap is is getting worse so we apply our
repetition and in particular we use the
anchored para petition - for some
technical reasons basically we want to
have the best integral bond that that we
that we can have and then like combining
all the steps you have a cap preserving
compression of no more games this table
is game using sealed it level cell
functions you end up with again say on
function but it's much smaller size so
okay you you know you have compression
serum and so it's fit like this it's an
algorithm with input V an output of the
shot to both V and V sharp a pair of
Turing machines and and the conditions
we have is that this compressed games
they are much smaller index but they can
simulate the larger game in the sense
that if larger game has very warm then
the smoking has very one if the large
game has very almost half then
compressed game has been almost half and
also have the interesting ten compounds
that the compressed game would use at
least that amount of information in in
the uncompressed game entanglement and
uncompressed game in some fixed bound
because of the use of entanglement in
the introspection so that's the the
technical serum that we want and once
you have that what you can do now is to
define a Turing machine
so we were trying to prove that I'm the
star he goes to Hawaii and
basically we want to reduce the halting
problem to deciding the value of a game
and this is how we do is to it and so
for any act or omission hen we define
actual machine could be hot or the
decider for the for the hot game first
you would simulate the game and for n
steps
index input of this decider if M already
false in this in steps we accept
otherwise we don't know then we just
compress the decider itself to get a
compressed decider and we only accept if
the compact set up would accept so
intuitively because the compression
serum our country says that the
compressed game of index n is simulating
what this uncompressed game D hot over 2
to the N index so it's essentially
checking in this step like to simulate
m42 to lane steps and and if it holds an
accept so as you can see like if and
courts eventually then then the game
should it would detect this so
crease lucrative serum is used here
because like we are defining a Turing
machine well specifying the the Turing
machine we use its description and
that's good maybe comparative but that's
allowed and by the cleanest current
serum so that's the tour mission D Hawk
is well defined and and based on this
definition we can claim that if emmafox
then the integral value of this game of
particular size than zero weapons zero
is where the compression works so
compression setting works for in at
least some fixed constant zero and the
way to see this like if if this to
machine thoughts in T steps and if like
T is less than and then you would
already see this in this first step and
of course the value is one but if like
for example it's it's in between N and
two to the n then by this single
argument the value of this in hot we hot
on index n because if T is larger than n
it doesn't really hot in except in the
first step so we move on to the second
step and and and will only decide except
if the shop accept so it's the value of
the other VN compressed game and by the
by the compression theorem does this be
hot at the index of 2 to the N is very
one because Steve's lesson to the N and
by the definition accept so this equals
to 1 and then the compression services
at this this value is also so by similar
arguments you can you can prove that no
matter what she is as long as some
integer you can prove that term discards
one and you can prove that
when m does not hot then this value is
the most half and that's for that we
need to use entanglement the game is
using larger larger amount of
entanglement and and for the game to
achieve area half there's no fixed bound
of entanglement and that's another way
to say that the value of the integral
value of this game is at most half okay
we can also to express the separation
between these two values and we do this
by defining a different or a machine
where we first compute the the game and
then we won't mpro tree and to test
whether it stops until our key word
detects whether the game has value
commuting value less than 1 if less than
1 well hot and less than 1 and but like
in our case if empty hierarchy hearts we
accept and if doesn't hop yet then we do
the compression and it's very similar to
to the computers definition so our claim
is that now the integral value is in
most half and the committee batteries so
the proof of that the integral value is
at most half is very similar to the
previous proof you just argue the
entanglement that we've been using but
like to see that the value has to be 1
for the commuting of the value assume
that the value is studying like it's
less than 1 then we know that empty
hockey would detect this and and then
from that you would you would you would
see that integra value would be 1 and
but like we know that the community
value is always value the main thing
about you and it's a contradiction so it
cannot be that this value is less than 1
has to be 1 so that's all the power that
we get from this compressed
no wisdom to to to summarize we have
been constructing recursive
gap-preserving compression of normal
form two to four one-run protocols it's
a four very special a family of
particles and are using this compressed
level a confession lemma and cleans the
Christmas serie we are able to prove
that are ye the [ __ ] problem
has a particle and fi using web star and
as we already know that MF star isn't
are you so the code he follows and this
of course gives not a bouncer to
citizens problem and and
embedding problem so there's some open
problems one is can we have simpler
proofs while the people has 160 pages
but I think the idea is once you have
all this ingredients it's a very
modulized
proof another question is there is class
related to I'm a pishtaco my Pico where
are you defining the variables in terms
of the commuting operator Charlie's and
and we conducted that this class is
actually kawaii note that these two
codes are different meanings and also
it's interesting maybe to come up with
explicit counter examples to the
concentrating problem about others is
like we are a sequence of implication
known in the literature okay so to
summarize it's very interesting to look
at our results from the historical
perspective that in physics in computer
science in mathematics and a lot of
exciting results starting from the
series and we visited in 60s 70s and to
90s or related to this results and
basically by using computer science and
information techniques and resolving
problems in physics and any mathematics
thank you much for your attention and so
because it's a very condensed talk with
of concepts being mentioned but I guess
it's a good opportunity because we have
three talks because you have cut out
flavor of how the proof works and and
this thing looks like a map and could
hope that will help you to find your way
if you really want to understand the
proof okay thank you thank you for the
talk I think we have a time for a few
questions if someone wants to ask
something it's the right time in Q&A if
you are an attendee or you can just
unmute yourself if you have a list so we
have a question in the chat oh sorry it
was not a question just I will choke
laughing all right so I wanted to ask
when so when you apply the PCP theorem
then you know the PCP theorem is applied
to like a particular like circuit not
here like you apply the PCP in a way
that it also depends on this unknown
long string that the player samples
themselves so how do you how do you
check the content of that string somehow
because it needs to be included in the
PCP proof in some way yeah that's a good
question so remember we have like four
steps and
so the PCP is after the organization we
have a cane where the question sizes are
as small and also sizes are big that's
your starting point and what this PCP is
checking is because after normalization
a localized player knows all this
question x and y and BMP for this game
and for this again before the
organization so the authorized player
can compute the cross-appeal proving
that that the wear fur would have
accepted this question and also
typically that's most of the Catalan is
happening in this PCP part but of course
it will also make sure that the pops
also and/or Christ are consistent and
it's not obvious that you can do this
because once you encode this using the
PCP people to extract out the part of
the information and that's some extra
condition actually motivation that we
have to implement in this recipe step so
basically we would make sure that you
can easily extract the information from
dora christ to check across god but the
main part of the PCP is checking whether
the decider is excess back there's a
decider in this in this step and and
want to make sure that this decider
would accept
we're closed game
so sorry thanks the decider you don't
like the idea is that it's like you
don't need to send me the proof you just
need to send me TC people that convinced
me that I would have to accept it if you
send me all the proof but or the
volatilized player no or the information
and that's cushion thing because
previously when we use this some
cracking code then there's no one no
none of the players can can do this
because they only know random
information and so that's really hard to
work with but now with GPRS we have an
Oracle eyes approver who knows
everything and that's where this allows
you to apply this PCP technique
okay if there are no more questions then
let's thank again all the speakers of
today Alex VM Joan and shank Frank and
yeah thank you for your great dogs